let's hit it and credit this episode of
why it's awesome is gonna be a little
bit different because first of all I'm
going to talk about something a little
bit different which is a podcast one of
my favorite podcast I listen to quite a
few but this is this is absolutely one
of my favorite and also it's actually
not gonna be mostly me talk about it how
I'm gonna talk a little bit about why I
love this thing but then it's actually
gonna go to an interview with the cast
most of the cast but I'll talk about
that in a minute
so improvised weapons is a real play D&D
podcast with good current cast is the
dungeon master and five players all
playing their characters just working
their way through an adventure and I
love it
I tried these sorts of things before
both in video and podcast form and I've
enjoyed some of them most of them I
dropped off on this this one I think
ultimately comes down to the cast and
full disclosure at this point having now
interviewed them I've met almost all of
them but one of them John he he was a
friend of mine long even before that
this podcast started it he actually used
to podcast with me on one of my
podcasting ventures that that ended up I
kind of we didn't have the time for it
anymore
so and I also support them on patreon so
there's your full disclosure notices in
any case I I really love the heck out of
this and I think a big part of why it's
so good is that these aren't just you
know people who who play D&D they are
comedians and more importantly they're
improvisers because you know you can get
comedians on some leg does you can get
something like Harmon quest which is fun
and and I enjoy well enough but you know
that they'll get in there and they'll do
jokes and do what have you but well I
think the benefit of having improvise
they are used to taking no sudden turns
of events and doing something narrative
ly with them so it's not just about
making a joke in the moment it's about
okay how can we maneuver this as a story
and I think as a result this this
podcast has a much better flow to the
story into the characters then most
other role-playing podcasts that I've
listened to and Sam is really good as a
dungeon master so I just love the heck
out of this thing and I think that's
enough for me and I'm gonna give you the
chance to meet this cast most of this
cast so one of the players Aaron who
plays a Owen the high elf wizard he was
not at the recording that I was able to
sit in on and interview the cast for
also one of the cast members Nicole who
plays hola SH the half-orc barbarian she
had to leave so she vows out partway
through this and also unfortunately
they're recording equipment at a couple
of points kind of wreaked havoc with my
recording equipment and I ended up with
feedback so there are a couple of times
where like I'll ask a question of the
group as a whole but you'll only get
answers from like two or three of them
and the reason why you're not getting
answers from everybody is because I had
unusable audio and I hope that you'll
stick around for the interview and I
also hope you guys will check this out
because the characters are phenomenal
casseon is the most amazing blowhard you
will ever come across your fake is so
good hearted because of so many problems
by that fact the ever-growing list of
alternate personas for illed of and then
you know hey Owen
having zero tact at any point no sense
of diplomacy and then hola SH is Ola SH
is just amazing hola sh makes my heart
sing and I hope that you'll check it out
and get a sense for why that is or maybe
you'll get a little bit of a
sense of it from this interview but
let's meet the cast
[Music]
welcome to improvised weapons last time
on the show the party continued
investigating vb fungal calves
this time going down the right hand
tunnel in it they discovered a line of
large mushrooms using their recently
acquired bag of tricks they summoned to
help her Templeton the rat to test for
traps and Templeton was quickly done in
by the mushrooms hidden cold with light
tendrils they avenged his death and
we're ready to simply go around back
through the left-hand tunnels until
anyone spotted some gemstones embedded
in the ceiling in the middle of the path
they dealt with the rest of the
mushrooms so they could harvest the gems
unmolested and managed to get four of
the five out of the ceiling
moving on deeper into the ground they
heard noises that sounded like a
settlement that came to a turn around
which was a writer light than they've
seen so far peering around Casio saw
much to his surprise a village and that
is where we pick up casseon you've just
peered around the corner into the
largest cavern you've seen so far
you see rows of igloo shaped clay huts
lining a central thoroughfare
bioluminescent mushrooms everywhere as
well as some little freezers and central
locations what grabs your attention
though is the semicircular line of ten
spheres being brandished towards the
cavern mouth each is held by for lack of
a better word a mushroom and with your
natural twenty stealth roll from last
time they don't seem to notice you right
now but that's unlikely to last very
long if you keep your head all right so
this is the cast of improvised weapons
everybody say hi so welcome Cassy it
says welcome of course he does well go
around the table we'll just start with
with John because I actually like have
known him the longest so it's it's a
cheat but we'll just do quick
introductions of
both yourself and the character that
you're playing I'm John Van luleå and
playing your fix storm hammer the dwarf
cleric of the group what's the worst
that could happen we get in a fight like
we were going to in the first place but
this time we're not lighting it we're
just coming through and being ourselves
nobody like the leader I'm Fred Naaman
and I play Cassie and fun demos human
bard okay let me pitch this to you guys
the three of us turn ourselves into
mushrooms and we come back leading your
'[ __ ] in chains like we're like we've
caught a prisoner and we try to just
just walk right through things I
couldn't take three mushroom men
I am Sam Curnutt and I played everybody
that's not one of these guys I'm Lindsay
dad I play the half elf warlock Hilda of
Carter onna
that's a tooth and I'm Nicole Sisk and I
play the half-orc hola Schmucks which is
fine because that wash doesn't want to
understand all right
now what is everybody's background in
tabletop gaming is this was this new for
you starting this or does everyone have
experience with DMV prior to the show I
okay I'll start I have been super into
like fantasy and sci-fi for a long time
and I have wanted to play D&D basically
forever but aside from like a few sort
of scattered like you know short run
games with friends here and there
I just never like knew enough other
people that were into it or like we're
able to get a game together to actually
play in a regular long-running game so
this has been a dream come true for me
yeah I played in college for like a
semester because I only knew one person
and he got like a game going and just
invited me to go along I was like sure
that sounds like a thing I could
participate in
and then yeah I actually I think I
remember meeting Fred and we talked we
would like talk about wanting to play
D&D
but just like never forming a group or
having the time so yeah this has been a
great way to get to play again I played
as a kid with my dad and my brother but
hadn't played in like 20 years and then
until Sam was like hey want to be on a
podcast with like all these people that
you do company with anyway I played as a
kid and kind of left it for a bit there
actually went to a summer camp that had
a D&D class to learn how to play which
is ridiculous
then didn't play for a while played in
college with a long ring game for all
four years and then moved to Chicago
kind of lost it for a bit played other
tabletop stuff but always wanted to come
back to it was always trying to get a
game going but no one would do it move
back here and play with the group that I
knew from college for a bit and then was
talking to Sam in the box office I don't
like how much I miss playing regularly
or having a regular thing and he was a I
had this great idea do a podcast so we
both like critical role just be really
cool to put together I'm like sign me up
I will do anything you need and so this
has been really fun to kind of get back
into it and learn 50 which I've never
played before I'm gonna assume the
dungeon master was a complete newcomer
to this and be surprised I didn't I
didn't start playing D&D until I turned
29 I'm I turned 30 for a week from today
so no I I didn't play for the first time
until I turned 29 I kind of run into
some friends from college at another
college friend's wedding and we all
happen to live in the same city but like
never hang out together and one of my
friends was like oh man you know we used
to play D&D all the time I'd love to get
a group going and my wife and I were
like we've never played D&D before let
us try this thing you call Dungeons &
Dragons and he set up one session we
were playing three five and we just
[ __ ] loved it we had the best time so
we kept that campaign going for almost
over a year basically until we moved up
to Vermont and then I was just kind of
going through withdrawal I was watching
all of the the a kink games from Penn
Kade and and I got into critical role
and I was like I hate watching this and
not playing it's no fun so I was like I
know what I'll do I'll make a podcast
and trick my friends into doing it so
they feel an obligation to actually show
up hey it works what everybody's
proudest character accomplishment saving
Kritika like saving her in the trial yes
okay yes so the for those who are
unaware the very first portion of the
campaign involved rescuing and missing
boy and in doing so the party came up
against a group of Cobalts the leader of
which they kind of took a shine to and
instead of killing her they took her
back to town and forced the local and a
government to put her on trial and then
they were defense attorneys and they got
her off on community service because of
speech will be turned to ash if that is
the case yeah Oh wash made a very
impassioned speech and and and that was
it customer customer yeah that was a no
I did not intend to have to design a
system or courtroom drama edition
dungeons dragons I'm not mad that I had
to do copyrights and Kurt it lives is
probably yeah
like a hundred percent Carroll
but the the seductress in mom jeans yeah
there's an actress in mom juice she
likes it rough who knows he likes it
rough and she managed to get the robbed
that's where I got the rod at the
package keeper which has been very
useful for casseon let me see it's
probably III was really happy with how
the whole like heists episode went where
we had to break you know into Ghul
Rick's house and like do all of that
stuff like I just felt like that was
like who's like one of the only like
instances ever of like our plan going
like exactly according to plan as far as
we had planned it you might have already
answered the follow-up question we'll
still but the ball question is what were
your most epic character fails at but
the reason you can think about that
while John answers the proudest
accomplishment perhaps accomplishment
for him has been free our fake it has
been that he it's kind of on over
washing he spared more lives and he's
killed so he's been able to influence
the party a lot not to murder everyone
and in that way kind of like pleases God
so he got to meet his goddess which was
amazing for him like no one gets to do
that
which is ridiculous so he's very proud
of that he's proud that he's standing up
for that and so there's not one I mean
correct ACCA's the first one that comes
to mind like we're not gonna kill her
and there was a whole argument why are
we killing this cobalt because we can't
yeah your your enemies are net alive
exactly in the black it's nice it's
actually safer to be our enemy than just
like a random bystanders
sad but true
yeah so so biggest fails I guess for me
going crazy
hallucinating
yeah that was in it which was also fun
to do when I was like oh my god like
everything which is going wrong at that
point II was trying to protect everybody
doubles in trying to climb a wall yes I
don't know if this counts as an epic
fail but it was like a failure like it
was I was attempting to do something
that I thought would be really epic
and totally failed to swing on that rope
in the burning warehouse jumping to mind
but I do feel like it was like just like
overall biggest failure is perhaps I
don't maybe not like just like putting
the party in danger because she's
because she made a pact with her mere
presence is a fail I don't know it seems
like maybe some things are happening to
the party that like what happened if she
hadn't joined today how many of you
already have a backup character made in
case you die I have to actually she's
got to fred has to aaron has one for
sure that may or may not appear
regardless I love the concept of it yeah
I can't speak for anyone
that character for the like improv show
that we did NSYNC and think yeah rinsing
what is she's a halfling bard a halfling
bard yeah yeah a party of halflings I'm
like a while yeah I can't
I think the listeners would all rebound
so there will always be we'd end up
having to do some kind of crazy like
crisis on Infinite Earths really and
like create a whole new timeline where
Olaf is alive so Sam you might have
already meant answered the first part of
this sort of two-parter but I'm gonna
try it anyway what was the biggest
divergence from your original plan that
the party took so many I mean definitely
sparing Kritika was was the first big
one that was definitely weird
sparing Ghul Rick that was one of those
things were like the moment that they
were like you know they decided to keep
him alive and bring them with him I was
like a sock has to come up with them
somehow I'm gonna make this happen
because they have to have consequences
for their actions
this is too weird and [ __ ] up so that
was that was definitely a big one
the even in the way it was Scott with
the The Fight Club I I had anticipated
because of introducing Terry and his
racism towards Olas then hola SH would
be the one who would get in the fight
and that she would be the one who gets
conscripted by Palin to to go to the
Fight Club but but that is not what
happened
the best week whatever yeah they they
continue to surprise me at every turn
which is probably for the better because
when we started this I was writing like
a lot of notes and I still write a lot
of notes but I've definitely pared them
down well because there's swathes of
things that just knew we'd never got to
and I'm gonna save them for other stuff
and maybe they'll rear their heads
somewhere down the line but I was just
like I was doing way more work than I
needed to
so now it's just like a scribble that
says like cave mushroom people my
question mark more like now I am at a
point where I I will write flowery
language if I have a specific thing that
I'm describing like the very end of this
this most recent episode for the
description of the the final cavern that
you guys walk into like that
I read word for word what I had written
for it because I had a very specific
image that I wanted to convey for it but
for like you know going into a
conversation
I'll just have things like if they ask
about this it'll say something like that
if they oh this something like that just
like bullet points and then the rest of
it is like I'm just gonna improvise this
cuz it's kind of what we do anyway just
like with the corpse you look on the
side of the road you didn't talk to yep
definitely didn't see that coming
let me come up with a whole story for
that guy what's the most effort you've
had to put into getting them back on to
the main quest honestly today wasn't
really that urgent um the most effort to
get them back into the story of things
they actually end up doing a lot of
course correction on their own because
there there definitely comes a point
where where at least one of them will be
like [ __ ] I just do this Nicole does
that a lot
and does that a lot when he's here of
like we've been talking too long someone
just needs to do something so let's do
it so they they end up doing that a lot
on their own there I can't think of any
particular instance but I would
definitely be willing to like be like
you know remember
things are happening while you guys are
chatting about whatever is going on
right so you know like but I can't think
of a specific instance in when it's
happened in the show in possibly at some
point we were like walking around
shopping for these or something else
like doing something very small then
you're like guys there's a library oh
yeah I mean there definitely was like
the walking around in basta fier and
like having the cultists appear around
every corner to try and get you guys to
like do something because you tried so
hard to tends to burn just realize I'm
dropping f-bombs listen left in there
and you know what if you listen to the
podcast it shouldn't be rough well I
mean I'm gonna bleep you so that's fine
didn't use tampering sense we should all
take a moment and talk about our
favorite curse word everybody's favorite
NPC and why will you make the dungeon
master happy I mean none of your
alternate personalities are in that's
the next question yeah I'm gonna say go
Rick because it was like kind of in love
with them was well she hasn't seen him
in the past 24 hours so then you know
the last thing she saw him he was truly
no it's like not a good I love his name
declare the gnome cleric Tesar captured
Oh yes chef I couldn't it I love Chester
as a concept because it was how he was
played Neela he's very much like chaotic
but also we intuitive all the crap out
of him yeah but like actually I think
that everyone's favorite is Blackwing
that's now like we I don't know I'm also
a big fan of the
interchangeable idiot bartenders I keep
waiting for one of the one of the
players ago do you have a brother who
does the same work I asked for this but
I think if I had to really choose a
favorite my favorite is pashed because
she's a badass like she's just so cool
and like like if I could if any of the
characters that I've designed as NPCs
like I've been total character sheets
for all of them and I played Kathak in
another game he's super fun but pashed
is the one that I'm like man if I could
do it all over again like I would like
start her at level one and I want to
play her all the way to level 20 because
like her backstory is really cool I
don't want to go into it too much cuz
you guys still may run into her again
but like her and her whole thing with
her pseudo dragon and just like the
storm sorcerer subclass is really cool
so yeah I think pastas pastas my
favorite babies I had pastas awesome so
I cook now relatedly everyone's fit
everyone favorite your favorite eel dog
alter-ego how many are you up to now
first of all where's the wait for Doug
Carol Alana's Chelsea rage yes sir
yeah I have a list that's a tough
question okay
like I love al honest but I gotta go
Doug yeah the original I mean Valier is
the original array of dog is the
original there is basically just ildo
and like a different story well like a
fake street-legal yeah exactly
no no yeah I yeah I don't know yeah yeah
and duck here with the catchphrase of
the podcast where do you sleep
yeah you sleep that is true
that wasn't actually a party to this
entire what encounters did you honestly
think that you might not all make it out
of a live the Goldberg fight honestly I
didn't believe we'd make it through that
with what they were doing us and that
stupid mirror like we were Oh nothing's
working and now we're all completely
screwed there was
oh yeah the UM the displacer beast fight
yeah this is really the only fight with
the displacer Venus and it might be
combat role William yeah and then there
were just a couple of times where I
think hola hola when you both went
unconscious yeah that's - yeah you both
had to you your Vic revived
hola Sh I think twice and cassian had to
pour a potion into him gloves mouth when
she went down yeah there was also the
hardest I walked into that halfway cuz I
missed the first party I saw a crack
where are we yeah that was that was one
that I designed to be difficult okay so
now for Sam relatedly what did you think
was going to be very easy that ended up
giving the party a lot of trouble I feel
like there are a lot of I mean dealing
with the whole argument over over go Ric
once they had like after him as far as
what to do with him
there's what those things were like if I
put myself in the shoes of any player I
would have been like let let's just kill
him because like what are we what are we
faffing about with this for I don't know
let me flip it on you then what was
something that you that you designed to
give them trouble though they just
breezed right past Oh the getting out of
the warehouse that was on fire I
expected them to have a much harder time
with that I had so many ideas for like
okay well to think of this
how it's gonna work into you this this
is how it's gonna work and they they
kind of were just like no let's just
leave and they just went out through the
sewer grate which was also one of the
options but I expected them to have a
much harder time figuring that out for
sure and I mean there certainly have
been things that that I don't take into
account how I've given them stuff that
will make it a lot easier like giving
them the decanter of endless water has
is something that I I don't think to
plan for that they have it like now
they're like when they travel they never
have to worry about bringing water with
them they're never going to to die of
thirst and in the middle of a desert as
long as they have that with Olas being
able to speak with animals like they're
never gonna be in a city like there's
always the option for them you know if
they get attacked by beasts while
they're out to like stop and try and
talk to them and then I have to figure
out what you know Joe tiger sounds like
or the Griffon yeah well that would I
kind of expect it would happen
well yeah it's definitely one of those
things were like you you forget as they
accrue more and more toys and abilities
that you have to think even further
outside of the box to make sure that
something is challenging but at the same
time as they get more toys and abilities
they forget that they have done well I
mean when you mentioned the Griffin and
I love finding out on the reaction cast
that you had scaled that giant fight for
the whole party it's something like
giving them giving old watch the ring of
jumping has completely changed combat
because now she can launch herself like
a hammer missile yes I love it
okay so which party member is most
likely to get everybody killed and why
is it yah wreck
[Laughter]
because he's your face so that says the
only joke question I have but I complete
sentence all right sorry I just wanted
to say like we joke about that a lot and
we give Derek a lot of crap for like
having no chill and like being
impossible at diplomacy but I actually
really like with it what it does for
like the story overall that we do have
like at least one party member who's
like not always down to sort of take the
easy way out and and like who like
actually you know wants us to like try
and be like the capital G good guys a
lot I don't know I just like the that it
froze an interesting wrinkle into a lot
of situations that uh that I appreciate
yeah I think it's it's a good balance
for the party I'm I'm always a fan when
not everyone in the party thinks exactly
the same way because I think that
happens far too often is people just
sort of go by party rule and they talk
about everything and then they just do
one decision it's like that's not how
people are people are different and they
have different opinions and they think
differently about things and they may go
they may like go along with something
that they don't want to do because
everyone else is doing it but they're
still gonna have something to say about
it and I think it's it's important to
carry that dynamic over because it makes
it that much more realistic well I also
every game I played beforehand was party
role was that type of thing you know you
always went along with it kind of not to
be a dick but I wanted to like play guy
like really play in his his viewpoint
versus like okay what's good for the
party and this has been fun because I
always feel that when I do it but it's
always good for us as well because we
get a lot of fun
so for the party if your character were
to die
how would you want them to go well
Cassie let's go ahead a blaze of glory
I mean clearly yaar '[ __ ] would want to
or I prefer to be like holding a line in
like a cavern like the last line of
defense everyone's running out
like that's the one he wants to go out
basically I picture Olaf wanting to die
while ripping off the arms of a god yes
but like with her bare hands oh yeah oh
yeah and then flipping him off imagine a
one would just want to be crushed by
books wants to be crushed under a
library yeah her own life yeah I think I
don't know I feel like Gilda wants to
die in a lover's arms yeah yeah either
11 his arms or or surrounded by lovers
yeah yeah I think casseon would
definitely want what he would want to go
out in like a blaze of glory doing some
like awesome heroic deed that like lets
everybody else like you you know achieve
something or like save the mission but I
think I would what I would if he if he
had to go what I would like for it to be
is like somehow the consequence of him
like finally being honest like he
finally decides to like not tell a lie
in a situation and and that's what gets
him killed
I think that like me as the player I'm
gone Elda if she has to go to like lick
sacrifice herself for the good of the
party you know like for the like because
she jump on the grenade yeah and they're
like yeah or like if it's a situation
that like she's kind of causing
like it's her you know
shower just coming out or someone trying
to attack her because of that because of
her pact
I would love as a player when you are
four to have his death means something
to some party so whether it's it turns
them into something else they become a
person or whether it's like you know
just basically showing the better nature
if everyone else he wants to be that
example or no they all just sigh and
relieve reaction is just like elation
jarvik dies they all stand around and
then his corpse farts and Aon goes yeah
so last question this one is for Sam so
I'm gonna call this the Breaking Bad
versus supernatural question so she's do
you have an endgame or you're just gonna
ride this out for as long as it possibly
can go okay so this this particular arc
of dealing with with elders ol has an
endgame and I have an arc in mind for
after that but I I would also be more
than happy to do this forever I mean
obviously within the confines of like
fifth edition Dungeons and Dragons you
kind of top out at level 20 and I think
the game kind of loses something a
little bit when when progression is no
longer a factor so I would I would
probably want to like get them to that
point and then do like one more cool
like we have all the cool [ __ ] now let's
go do some cool stuff thing and then
maybe retire it and and either move on
to different characters or something
else entirely
but I definitely I have endgame in mind
but there's also no clear path to it in
that we can do as many things between
now and then as we want to I you know I
will adjust whatever I need to adjust I
have a lot of when I started planning
this podcast I came up with a lot of
like vignettes of things that I want to
do and I'm still at the point where I'm
like picking and choosing like I can
slot this in here and slap this in here
and it still sort of works getting them
from point A to point B so I
keep doing that forever I come up with
stuff a lot way too often in fact I have
far more content in mind that I could
ever fit into one single campaign which
is probably for the best because I plan
on playing more than one in my life yeah
maybe maybe at some point we also switch
it up too and so you can play the game
and then what I'm allowed to play a game
you can see me know do all work all time
I just want to thank you guys again for
letting me be here and for making a
awesome podcast that I love the heck out
of oh absolutely
thank you so much thank you for being
here thank you for the amazing gifts
that you got yeah yeah and thanks for
just being awesome in general I mean
you've been one of our biggest
supporters for a long time they kind of
put stuff out there we really appreciate
it yeah so I mean obviously you're what
you're all out there in YouTube land
watching this video already but you
should watch some more is amazing well
thanks guys and look and until next time
bye alright folks that was it I I have a
number of podcasts that I really love
and if I eat unfortunately most of them
aren't recorded close enough to me for
me to be able to do this kind of thing
with them but if I ever get the chance
to interview like the the folks over at
relatively geeky or if I ever find
myself in the UK again I am gonna track
down the Leyland's from hey kids comics
and if I can if I can get my finances in
order I really want to try and get to
Heroes con next year where a whole bunch
of podcasting friends are gonna be so
who knows but for right now this is
probably for the foreseeable future the
only interviewee thing that you're gonna
get from me but god I love this podcast
it's it's so fun and it's so funny and
like any D&D campaign the first episode
or two you know give it a couple to get
into it as they get their footing and
Sam gets his footing with this group but
oh it's it's one of my favorite things
so hope you've enjoyed this what are
some of your favorite podcasts whatever
they are
coming down the comments let's talk
about it there's a whole bunch of
buttons and also links and things for
you to check out you know how all that
works so give that a look give the show
a listen and remember folks you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]